[Musique]
on
aujourd'hui le phare du solitaire
où
mon
[Musique]
le 12 septembre 1889 une équipe dirigée
par l'ingénieur en chef du port
d'inverness en écosse un certain
dominique readers embarquées sur la
vedette
océane en direction du phare de pentland
pour y accomplir une mission qui allait
devenir une grande première dans
l'électrification des phares britannique
est l'une des plus belles réussites
technologiques de cette fin de siècle
le phare de pentland but de la mission
russe était situé à 15 milles des côtes
dans le détroit de pentland appelé le
naufrageur de sinistre mémoire à cause
des courants qui s'y affrontent ceux de
la mer du nord et ceux de l'atlantique
et on aurait quand même pu attendre la
fin de l'équinoxe monsieur comme la le
marin qui pilotait la vedette demi de
crise quand ils eurent passé les balises
du chenal d'inverness
on va danser la charlotte tout à l'heure
en abordant le détroit et avec ces
satanés courant rider hutin gestes
d'impatience les moi j'attends depuis
cinq semaines pour savoir si le dénommé
raid rich man s'accepte de bon gré de
quitter le phare ou s'il va falloir le
déloger de force dans deux heures j'en
reçois tous les jours des dépêches de
londres qui exige la mise en service du
système électrique
c'est vrai que c'est un gars de
l'archipel monsieur c'est un sauvage
mon père dit que les habitants de
l'archipel sont tous des sauvages c'est
qu'il ya des repères ben le moose
délurée de l'océan on perdit qu'il parle
à des pierres et que la nuit il se
transforme en loup et en oiseau à cette
fadaise gamins en chat dominique aury
200 bon nombre et du sussex dont
l'esprit rationaliste s'irritait
toujours des bêtises que les écossais
inventait sur ceux de l'archipel y avoir
un grain remarquer le troisième homme de
la mission un certain qu'ils mcqueen
électricien l'empêchent monsieur
ajouta-t-il en haussant la voix parce
que le vent soufflait plus dur ce raid
avec mauss perd sa place de gardien de
phare avec notre nouveau système
électrique qui marche tout seul ne
m'étonne pas qu'ils refusent de s'en
aller s'il a une femme et des gosses à
nourrir et il sera à largement
indemniser maugréa l'ingénieur agacé
ils rencontrèrent le brouillard à
l'entrée du détroit mêlé à une forte
houle est un peu devenu le fer de
pentland aurait déjà dû signaler les
passes de l'ouest en actionnant sa corne
de brume mais on n'entendait rien et ça
commence bien
s'énerve à dominique l'idée m'est avis
que le gars moss est en train de se
chauffer les pieds chez sa belle à
pomona criaki lee mcqueen orient tant
mieux pour lui mon gré à l'ingénieur il
va nous manquer pour l'accostage comme
la grégory qui connaissait bien sa
vedette remet pas le ponton de pentland
dans la pluie et le brouillard même vu
de près le phare été sinistrées dans un
rare état de décrépitude
elle est un sacré courage pour livre là
dedans pense à dominique readsoft
frissonne
j'aime parler enfin abandonné et qu'il y
entre ses dents
j'entends des coups d'oeil méfiant vers
la porte basse deûle à tournoyer à marée
haute
comme le reste de lino et vous avez vu
fille a soudain luz
tous ces oiseaux sur l'écueil le
brouillard ne s'accrochait plus aurenche
et tourmentée sur lequel était érigé le
vieux phare on y voyait nettement une
multitude de mouettes grise agglutinés
les unes contre les autres
[Musique]
salord s'exclama gregor ne s'envolent
pas quand on approche on dirait j'aime
quand les oiseaux partout les sons du
diable lens à l'électricien en crachant
par dessus bord il va falloir les
déloger pour transporter de matériel
pendant quelques secondes
ceux de l'oceane hésitait la vue de ces
oiseaux muet coller au rocher malgré un
vent mauvais qui soulevait leur plumage
dans un mouvement désordonné mais
désorienté et les alarmes est dominique
raid et ce fut le premier à réagir il
s'empare d'une caisse à lons
monde at-il furieux contre lui même
cette fois ne perdons pas de temps
messieurs le fracas des lames contre les
brise on n'y coupe pas la parole
le vent se fit plus violents et les
manoeuvres de débarquement en furent
compliquées mais le pire était d'avoir à
traverser en les chassant à coups de
botte cette marée de moyens dolente qui
paraissait malade et qui réagissait
mollement à leur coup de pied rageur
ils étaient plus de deux heures de
l'après midi qu'en sus ans et soufflant
le coeur et train d'une sourde angoisse
ils se retrouvèrent devant la porte
close du phare de paint ball hand
derrière eux les serrant de près les
oiseaux venaient de refermer la nasse
vivante des plumages des têtes au bec
crochu et des petits yeux au regard du
même dominique reader est un geste de
répulsion mais ces oiseaux maudit
viennent de l'archipel
rick hannah mcguinn l'émoi de grease
viennent toutes de là bas elles ont la
couleur du brouillard et ont l'air à
moitié morte
le gars moss lui doit avoir l'habitude
c'est un compatriote en shérif grégory
les bestioles s'énerve on dirait le tas
d'amis perben l'année attendu qu'un
mouvement imperceptible la gîte est à
présent les oiseaux comme s'ils s'ébroue
est lentement nous celui de ce nom rocha
pas enfoncé la porte grégory thil
brièvement et mon père dit que dans
l'archipel ils se nourrissent de sang
humain et que la nuit il se transforme à
une gifle magistrale venait d'arrêter le
moose
dominique lui l'est regrettait déjà son
geste voilà qu'un gamin lui mettait les
nerfs en pelote à présent et quand la
porte du phare céda sous la hache du
marin une suffocante odeur de salpêtre
les pris à la gorge devant le boyau noir
et malodorants qui montaient à l'assaut
des ténèbres épaisse comme celle du puy
mary gorille s'effaça avec ariane
précipitation pour laisser son chef
prendre la tête de file il se savait
beau être un homme de sang froid une
mauvaise sueur lui picota la nuque quand
il mit le pied sur la première marche à
la troisième il buta sur quelque chose
de mou qui lui file entre les jambes non
de dracula précipitamment la chance à
l'amp et se cogna mcqueen qu'il faille
est entraîné dans sa chute
heureusement le moose tenait une autre
langue mais l'aspect repoussant
d'humidité des murs qu'ils allaient
devoir feront les et dieu sait quoi
d'autre failli avoir raison de leur
courage
seule l'idée de retraverser en sens
inverse cette marée d'oiseaux apathiques
les dissuade à de faire demi tour
la présence des oiseaux grille avait
tout bouleverser elle avait quelque
chose de malfaisants et de tragique
j'aime pas ça comme la kylie mcqueen
dans le dos boys ces bestioles vous avez
remarqué comme elle nous serrer de près
quand on a commencé à monter vous avez
peur mcqueen se moque un ingénieur dont
le coeur se contracter de façon
désagréable
bien sûr j'ai pu l oms a longtemps
sèchement
une demi heure plus tard ils durent
s'avouer l'évidence tous les magasins du
phare ces espaces de quelques mètres
carrés à chaque palier ne contenaient
rien ne justifie que pentland et était
habitée un jour il y avait juste une
grande quantité d'huile minérale pour
alimenter les lances
or cela a été confirmé par les pêcheurs
comme par les vapeurs danois qui
empruntaient le détroit
le phare fonctionner encore la paye
[Musique]
c'est impossible à un homme de faire
l'aller-retour pour mon à peine trente
deux fois par jour dans une barque
articula grégory doc d'année atone il
serait avec moss c'est comme s'il
n'avait pas existé
demus même dans la chambre des landes où
il se tenait à présent à part l'aspect
net des lampes
il n'y avait rien
rigoureusement rien juste des plumes
d'oiseaux à chamakh bouillir les
papillons du pied les plumes qui
jonchaient le sol le mystère de neige
franchement si mystère
kylie mcqueen après un coup d'oeil à
grégory crachats sa chique et monsieur
louron sarthois voyez vous ça dépasse
notre entendement cette affaire vous ne
pouvez plus quitté le pharma guen et
pont dit l'ingénieur d'une voix fatiguée
la marée est haute
il vous faudrait plongé sous l'eau pour
passer la porte s'ouvrit eu un cri mal
gré il est musulman de la mairie le
tumulte du vent et greten est et d'où il
fut aussitôt suivie de quelques grilles
allemand et tard puis bruit confuse
étouffé venant de l'intérieur du phare
enfin un vacarme infernal éclater à tout
en bas comme si des centaines d'oiseaux
s'embarrassait pas monté à la seule
peine clan et de ses son équipe de leurs
airs quelques secondes paralysé de
terrain soudain dominant le tumulte il
eu un bruit tout proche un battement
d'aile maladroite qui se heurtait au mur
de la tour un second froissement grégory
dornoch réagi le premier il se jeta sur
la porte de la chambre et la repousse a
violemment les autres eurent la vision
de bec de plumes et de serre près de la
tête de leurs compagnons et des
hurlements de rage puis plus rien
rien que la rumeur assourdi des
battements d'aile et des crimes en
moduler comme des voix humaine qu'il y
avait rejoint grégory est appuyée de
toutes ses forces contre le battant
tandis que l'ingénierie des tirs elle
est à rejeter que d'une peine avec une
vélocité rares et accumulait les caisses
de matériel électrique
aucun d'eux nous est imaginé le
répugnante à d'oiseaux se bousculant
derrière la porte est aussi la viande
crue un halte à quilly d'année regard et
dominique ribeyre leur tendaient d'une
main tremblante une bouteille de whisky
qu'il venait d'extraire de son sac qu'il
y ait grégory la vie d'air il n'en
fallait une seconde pour lui et le moose
à présent le bruit avait cessé comme une
abominable marais les oiseaux avaient
reflué et on n'entendait plus que le
fracas des lames contre les cueille et
le hurlement du vent c'est alors qu'il
dira que la nuit tombait river se garda
sa montre elle marquait quatre heures on
va passer la nuit au phare mais ça tu il
tomber mais personne n'aurait seulement
entrebâillé la porte de la chambre à ce
moment là
échangeant peu de paroles il véniat
terre quelques vivres on avait du whisky
mais on allait manquer d'eau dominique
rider s'alluma peu après les langues du
phare mais régla et s'attaque à presque
avec soulagement au montage de la future
lampe électrique qui les malouines
mais dès les autres les regardait
refaire personne ne songeait à dormir
[Applaudissements]
quand l'horreur arrive à nous est
absorbée par les dernières mises au
point de la langue
ils n'en mesurent tous qu un
pressentiment
[Musique]
cette fois les cris amant provenait du
dehors mais les aux vagues qui se
fracasse est plus loin sur les brisants
mais trois ans mais l'oms qui s'était
spontanément redresser et avait failli
courir à la porte
si mobilisèrent le coeur battant fixant
les grandes baies vitrées aux quatre
points cardinaux de la chambre grigory
parcouru la pièce du regard mais il n'y
avait rien et dire qu'on n'a même pas
une arme à l'ats qu'il mcguinn en
interceptant son coup d'oeil les oiseaux
attaque hier par le nord est de
l'archipel grande à mcguinn entre ses
dents on aurait cru que seuls l'impact
de leur masse sur la vitre épaisse du
phare comptait les premiers oiseaux
fürth écrasé contre le ver qui tremble a
violemment rider senti la sueur lui
coulait dans le dos qui l'avait repéré
une soupente avec sa trappe
il pourrait peut-être s'y entasser au
cas où on ne pensait pas que les vitres
tiendrait longtemps les oiseaux attaque
et aussi au sud
tentant de briser les vitres du bac et
des griffes les yeux fous des centaines
de martèlement dans une clameur violente
est furieuse une masse de plume de
griffer de paix qu un spectacle
effroyable
elles permettent une nausée et ferment
les yeux la soupe arthrite en donnant
l'ingénieur au même moment les mouettes
attaqué à l'est et à l'ouest la chambre
des lampes trembla sous le choc
une vitre exploser en mille morceaux et
le vent s'engouffre à en hurlant soudain
alors que dominique reid se jetait en
avant pour plonger le dernier dans la
soupente les oiseaux cessèrent leur
furieux martèlement même ceux qui
avaient envahi la pièce se retirèrent
reid et ses compagnons assistèrent
médusés au refus des oiseaux fous c'est
alors que le monstre harry van den père
ben hur la ride santis a raison
chanceler seigneur dieu leur mur à
grégory et c'était vraiment une grande
faiblesse pour un mécréant de sa trempe
il y avait là encore indistincte est
mêlé au brouillard
la forme d'une créature ailée
gigantesque auxerre terrifiante
d'oiseaux de proie
elle approchait du phare dans un vol
d'une lenteur effrayante dans la chambre
tourbillonnait avant tumultueux les
soufflaculs une mort d'angoissé
vire les noms à luynes vaciller dans le
vent puis faiblir en chantant la
monstruosité est né à tenniel phare la
tête sur l'allemand ce avant de
s'évanouir
à l'instant de la dernière lan pourrait
il vit le masque grimaçant d'une tête
admis humaines au bec crochu de rapaces
se profiler devant la vitre brisée
ouverte sur le large
dominique rey de silence à ors de la
soupente comme un fou revenus des
réseaus du relooking mcqueen
il va vous restez se perdit dans une
bourrasque de l'obscurité générés
il entend dire un craquement à feu le
hurlement dribbles les devis nerfs
l'ombre immense des ailes déployées et
dessert tendue vers la chambre
soudain une lumière inouïe incandescente
jaillit devant dominique ridosz qui leur
tournait le dos
l'ingénieur avançait vers l'ouverture et
l'horreur qu'ils allaient pénétrer dans
la pièce il a il bégayait grigori
électricité dit qu'il est dans un
souffle
regardez regardez regardez est décrié
riait comme un fou agitant devant lui
les fils lumineux qui jetait des éclair
aveuglant
le monstre avait poussé un hurlement
rock avant de basculer en arrière dans
la nuit et le brouillard je les aveugles
et regarder mcqueen les satanées
bestioles
regardez-le est elle sans pluie elle
fuyait les mouettes grise de pentland et
la monstruosité et l'est aussi
bon
si l'équipe readers au lieu de tomber
dans les bras les uns des autres avaient
suivi encore quelques secondes leurs fui
en direction de l'archipel des orcades
les aurait découvert le vol tragique qui
d'un gigantesque oiseaux aux yeux
aveugles brûlé par l'éclat trop violent
de l'électricité ces immenses elle
soutenu par des centaines de mouettes et
père
chaque mystère dit on doit posséder une
explication alors puisqu'il faut une fin
à cette histoire j'ai choisi de laisser
parler reid est lui-même le froid et
méthodique ingénieurs d'inverness
dans une lettre adressée des années plus
tard un ami à qui il confiait ces
événements
plus le temps passe amy et moi je crois
mes propres sens tant de mystère un jour
quelques semaines après notre expédition
à peine plande j'ai voulu connaître ce
fameux raid rick moss
l'ex-gardien de pentland je suis allé
dans l'archipel à pomona où il habite
mais hélas j'ai appris qu'un terrible
accident l'avait rendu aveugle à peu
près à l'époque de notre mission a punk
landes
je n'ai pas eu les détails de l'accident
et comme réderie cmos ne voulais pas me
recevoir sa famille m'a longuement
expliqué qu'il était un homme très
solitaire et qu'il regrettait de ne plus
être gardien de pentland ces gens m'ont
reçue très généreusement ils ne sont pas
du tout les sauvages qu'on dit bien à
toi
dominés cris des ingénieurs électriciens
londres le 15 mai 1892
[Musique]